تلاحق تحديدا فيما يجري ما يتعلق بمطار
مروي اخر المستجدات عن اشتباكات تحدث الان
غربه مطار مروي قلت لنا قبل قليل اسامه
لانك تستمع لاصوات اطلاق نار وبالتالي كيف
نفهم ما جرى يوم امس والحديث عن السيطره
وما يحدث هذه الساعات وظهور هذه الصور
والتاكيد بان مازال هناك قوات من الدعم
السريع موجوده في المطار والاشتباكات تحصل
الان اسامه
عبد القادر يعني حتى الساعات الاخيره من
ليله امس كنا نتحدث عن سيطره كامله للجيش
السوداني على مطار مروي الدولي وذلك طبعا
بحسب تاكيدات الجيش نفسه حين اكد السيطره
الكامله على المطار بل وقد قال بتاكيدات
مشدده قال انه اي برا قوات الدعم السريع
على الانسحاب بل رسم له خطه خروج امن من
داخل مطار مروي الدولي ويعني
المطار الحربي ايضا
فيما يبدو ان ان الانسحاب انسحاب قوات
الدعم السريع من داخل مطار مروي الدولي
كان بمعيه مجموعه من العسكريين المصريين
تقدر بنحب 27 عسكريا بمن فيهم الضباط
يستحبهم قوه اصطحبتهم قوات الدعم السريع
اثناء انسحابها من داخل
مطار مروي الدوله ولكن يبدو ان لم تتقدم
كثيرا هذه القوات في طريق انسحابها وسرعان
ما تجمعت في الطريق عودتها من مطار مروي
في عده مناطق بل التحقت بهذه القوات
مجموعه اخرى عززت هذه القوات ثم ربما عادت
من جديد اليوم صباحا واشتبكت بدات اشتباك
العنيفا بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه
والمتوسطه مع الجيش السوداني في المحيط
مطار مروي الدولي وبذلك موازين التفاصيل
الميدانيه ربما اختلفت في هذه بعض هذه
المعركه الاخيره التي بدات في وقت مبكر من
صبيحه هذا اليوم وبالتالي بعد هذه
التطورات قالت قوات الدعم السري عندها
يعني سيطرت على مطار مروي الدولي
وهناك ايضا يعني هناك ايضا
التاكيدات من الجيش السوداني
عبر مصادف
بقاله فعلا انها ان قوات الدعم السريع قد
يعني سيطرت على هذه المنطقه ولكن عزمت على
اعاده السيطره عليها على مطار مروه الدولي
خلال
الساعات القليله القادمه ربما بعد ذلك
يعني نتوقع هجوما اخر ومواجهات اخرى في
ميادين في ميدان المعركه شكرا لك يا اسامه
سيد احمد